well the muslim holy month of ramadan
begins next week
it's a time when people gather after
breaking their fast at sunset
and that's raising fears that this could
cause the coronavirus to spread
preparations are in full swing this mask
in islamabad is being cleaned by
volunteers
and there's plenty of hustle and bustle
at this market in the city
this as another wave of coronavirus
cases
wallops pakistan making preparations for
ramadan this year
a struggle
this is the second year of coronavirus
and it's affected our business
we're bankrupt and the reason is that
the markets shut down early in the
evening
shopkeepers aren't open so people don't
come to buy at the markets
our businesses depend on people
here in iraq street markets are quieter
than normal two
covet 19 is raging through the country
and many people are staying away from
crowded places
another muted ramadan awaits
the pandemic has forced us to stop
visiting each other during ramadan
and deprived us of our iraqi traditions
and customs
like visiting our relatives after we
break our fast
it's a painful situation for us and on
top of that
there'll be a curfew when we break our
fast
in indonesia the country with the
largest muslim population
cemeteries are busy with families
visiting the graves of loved ones
a tradition on the last weekend before
the start of ramadan
the holy month begins in just a few days
time and lasts
for 30 days